okay can you give me is that okay
welcome everybody to our talk playing
with Bluetooth for the beginning a quick
question who was here last year when I
gave the talk about Bluetooth is there
anybody who already saw the talk as you
at least a few hands cool so there will
be some few some things that that we
repeat but other things that are
definitely new because in this year
there was a lot going on with YouTube
basically last year I was here talking
about Bluetooth talking about my master
thesis and since then yesterday took
over the project and also many other
students joined the project and so this
will be like a wrap up of everything we
did and yeah my name is Dennis I'm the
security analyst at year in W Company
Heidelberg and I was a former student
here at the TU with Fisk as my
supervisor yeah I'm uske I work here so
it's the lecture hall there I sometimes
give lectures so it's very nice to be
here
yeah so demotivation since I started
doing this blue 2 stuff I'm following
the Bluetooth stick on Twitter more for
the fun because they have like really
funny tweets I think according to their
Twitter account I would assume that they
they gain the power of all of the world
just with Bluetooth so it's really
hilarious treats and if you follow their
Bluetooth market update it is like four
billion devices just in 2019 which they
approximate and I was like mate what is
world population so you would buy
something like have a Bluetooth device a
year I definitely buy more but it's only
for research
so what is bluetooth actually so I've
been working with bluetooth for a year
so III really spilled on know what
lutefisk I have to say but it is it is
blue it is blue yeah so can you tell me
what is blue - if you have been also
working with this yeah I actually wrote
a thesis about this basically as Yuri
said it's a 3000 page long standard
trying to define a wireless
communication protocol or protocol stack
that can be used to like communicate
between personal devices and yeah in the
standard basically is everything you
should imagine when you think about
Bluetooth that it's a system compared to
like the tcp/ip stack but you put in
there also the physical layer so for
example put in the whole Wi-Fi physical
layer and then also put in things from
the application layer for example HTTP
and then put it all together and then
you have a system like Bluetooth and
yeah what could possibly go wrong
so basically many things did go wrong
and we try to categorize them in
different layers and different section
where we could basically yeah take the
root cause of them and we begin with the
the user itself so in Bluetooth it's
still the user has to burden off also
contributing to the security of its
connections so for example if you pair
with a Bluetooth device you usually get
presented with a pin and if you don't do
this pin comparison correctly then you
might be man middled for example then
there's other things and problems with
for example the implementation of
Bluetooth inside the various operating
systems because a huge part of Bluetooth
is basically implemented for each
operating system so Android iOS
Windows Linux and one famous incident
was basically the release of many
vulnerabilities under the codename blue
Bourne
some of you might remember that that was
quite a shock because there were so many
different vulnerabilities targeting all
kinds of operating systems so Windows
Linux iOS and Android all were affected
some more than the other so for some
there were remote code execution over
Bluetooth for others there was things
like you could basically intercept IP
traffic from the device over Bluetooth
and there are also other kinds of
attacks so for example the Neno attack
we already showed in some of our
previous talks which is the no input nor
output attack where you basically just
try to man the middle pairing set up by
manipulating how the devices communicate
with each other because basically what
they do when they pair to each other is
they tell each other okay I have a
display or I have a keyboard and based
on that they decide how security
connection can be because if both
devices say hey I don't have a display I
don't have the keyboard how should you
compare the pin and basically an
attacker can't just yeah go into this
connection before even the encryption
starts and say okay we manipulate this
communication and both devices ping the
other has no display things like that
then there's other things that did go
wrong with this standard itself so as I
said the standard is almost 2,000 pages
long there's a lot that could go wrong
there and also Bluetooth is quite old
back in the days they used crypto which
was not as secure as today so for
example they used this safer plus cipher
which was not secure and broken in 2005
then later they when they introduced
Bluetooth Low Energy they they
introduced it less secure than the
current Bluetooth standard was already
Bluetooth to flow security yeah you
could say that not only low-energy
so basically Bluetooth
the classic Bluetooth in Bluetooth for
that Oh was already using a very good
pairing mechanism which based on
authenticated diffie-hellman and then
with low-energy they try to make it more
usable and also less secure and later
they fix it again and then for example
if you were here at my talk last year I
showed a demo of this fixed coordinate
in the liquor protect this is basically
also an attack that can be back traced
to the standard because in the standard
to define how the pairing mechanism
works its elliptic curve diffie-hellman
and basically they did not specify that
a certain key parameter should be
checked on both sides after they
exchanged keys and because they left out
this important note most of the vendors
just didn't check and so all of them
were vulnerable for this attack which I
showed last year so if you want to see a
demo of it you should go back to the
stream we had last year and then quite
recently there was also another attack
called not attack where an attacker can
basically force the device to just use
one byte of entropy for its key which is
also ridiculous and last but not least
there is implementation issues in the
firmware itself so this is also some
things that are quite hard to do
research but it's a place where we also
did a lot of research because we tried
to dig into this Broadcom failure and
find out how it works and also if
there's things that could go wrong yeah
and one second so now to say for the no
protects so it was not us doing this but
they used internal blue so it's a good
thing that we did it people are using
our assembly handwritten code it's great
so there's a lot of things that are not
really a security feature in blue 2 5
they introduced this fancy hopping
scheme so usually you would have
something like 37 datachannel and then
you just hop around them and once you
reach the last you begin again with the
first and go in circle and then they
said yeah let's do it a bit more random
and let's implement a funny
pseudo-random number generator but
basically if you know the connection
parameters you can
precalculate the whole sequence which is
65,000 entries and then you can filter
for this and actually do the hopping as
an attacker and still do sniffing and
injection actually um the guy who builds
this btle drag tool he found out how how
that works and how he can implement it
to follow on the newer bluetooth
connections so it's not really a
security feature it's more there to have
like a more reliable hopping that is
better distributed over the spectrum or
something like this so let's continue
with stuff that is obviously not a
security feature so on top of this three
thousand page standard someone thought
let's do another three hundred four
hundred pages of a bad specification
which is the Bluetooth mesh
specification and they have the DES
model of friendship
so nodes can become friends and then
there is super super set attacks which
are denial of friendship for example and
so the reason for this is that they did
not build the encryption properly of
course so they're using a lot of
encryption keys and the colleague of
mine who found that he was calling Luke
6 saying like hey guys something is
broken with your security and they were
like do you want to become a little sick
member no I want to report issue then
use our web form the web form is do you
want to become a glute of cig member no
I just want to report something and then
the feedback in the end was like you
know we are using a lot a lot a lot of
encryption keys but it's really just for
a reliable communication
okay okay I guess and then even better
so there's a text there is no blue 25.1
hardware yet I think in your iPhone
might have it or something but there's
currently none available but let's break
things just as they are specified in the
standard by not so what the Bluetooth
angle of arrival idea is you want to
save money so you are not physically
building a receiver that has multiple
antennas for localization but what you
do is you have two antennas and for the
direction-finding you need to see the
difference of the signal how it arrives
at the two antennas but since you only
have one RF switch connected to one
physical receiver what you do is you
first measure the one signal on the one
antenna and then on the other antenna
and the time when you switch is actually
fixed in the standard so an attacker
would know the time and a receiver is
switching the two antennas so the
attacker can actually inject two
different signals to the two antennas
and fake the location which is really
nice I mean it's a super secure location
finding I guess
and so Francesca was building this kind
of things together with some other
people in an SDR and people were like
yeah but since it's a theoretical attack
you didn't try it on real hardware you
were just building it in STRs so I guess
it's not really an issue right it's just
where we're building those devices right
now but it's not not an issue yeah so
let's talk about boot of five that's
that's the thing that's in the devices
right now and we always try to buy cool
hardware that has moved to five and I
was really happy when they said the new
Raspberry Pi is going to have two to
five I was like oh cool a cheap device
that has blue to five let's just buy
hundreds of them and the cool thing is
like if I need to tell people yeah to
test this you need to buy a nexus 5 here
you don't get a nexus 5 anymore to test
this you need to buy a Samsung Galaxy S
tell me they are like you had right I
don't have this money no but if you tell
them by an emulation board they might do
that but and it's really just for this
specific case and people really do have
the Raspberry Pi already so it's a good
option for testing and I was really
really
checking like when will it appear even
as a Terran and air and Sun and then
suddenly someone was fitting during
recon at Montreal some was filtering my
rest before arrived and any other person
I was like can you install internal blue
and he and start internal universes can
in hex dump the D compile it and he was
like August 2014 I was like no blue to
five that was relieved 2016 can December
of 2016 can cannot be true and he said
like but I have a Raspberry Pi for and
like look into damask and everything as
I have added no way this thing has
bluetooth 5 and so I I looked him just
sitting in Monterrey superjet like
because I wasn't sold before and I
really couldn't believe my eyes it was
like yeah it says it's 2 to 5 but it
says compile it 2014 can we now do
something like having a new physical
layer that would be really awesome like
patching the chip to have a new physical
layer because that's defined in b25 that
would be cool what's inside the patch
the main thing that's inside the patch
is return Bluetooth version 5 next thing
that changed this vendor ID from from
prot come to Cyprus also very important
but I don't know I don't know
then next week I was like in class with
some people who also like to play with
Bluetooth and we paired with another
Bluetooth device checked what it's like
exchanging over the air the feature mask
and everything it's it didn't have any
any blue 2 5 features also if you ask
locally it's on it did not really have
the cool-blue 2 5 features we were
looking for so I was just walking around
in Kratz and asking the people who work
a lot of fruit of like what is mandatory
to be able to 5 compliant what is the
feature that you really need and they
were like all mandatory
oh I don't know I don't know I don't
know either
ok so yeah it's it returns rooted 5 at
least something at least something yeah
we could have done this we cut a fella -
yes because we are basically able to
patch the firmware ourselves
this is one of the parts you might find
familiar if you were here last year so
just for everybody else a quick wrap up
with our project we found out that
basically those Broadcom chips they have
an update mechanism because basically
when those chips ship they have to
firmware built into the ROM so read-only
memory they cannot actually do anything
about that so they came up with patching
mechanism which is called petram so that
they can ship updates and smaller
patches to the devices once they are
already built and also built into the
devices and yeah for the Nexus 5 there
were 128 patch RAM slots which is
basically one slot you can use to patch
4 bytes in the ROM which is only
temporarily it's a feature of the memory
management unit and yeah basically we
have 128 of such slots which is not much
but each slot basically could be used
for example to insert a branch
instruction in some function that you
want to patch so that you just branch
away from the function into the RAM
which is executable and then you put
just your other updated function or
whatever you want to do inside the RAM
and later a branch back so this is how
they use it to basically ship updates
and we found out how it works reverse
engineered it and now are also able to
do that ourselves
now you might think there's a problem
because it's only 128 slots and I'm not
sure how they calculated the size but I
guess they were bit off the other
limitation is basically the free RAM
that you also need because you need to
put new machine code on this device
which basically replaces the old
functions and when the device is
executing its normal bluetooth
operations
most of the RAM is already in use so
it's pretty limited in its updating
capabilities and the full extent
Niska found out later because I was
working with the Nexus 5 and so ok 113
of those slots were already induced
which made me a bit sad because
I wanted to play with this a lot and so
I didn't have much space for putting my
patches there but all the other devices
are actually way worse so what happens
if now a serious vulnerability would
occur in the codebase they would have to
update it but then other updates which
already got ship must be now like
dropped because they don't have much
slots left for most of those devices
yeah so I looked a lot into those those
patches recently and I think the
greatest one is the Samsung Galaxy s8 so
this one came out as the first put two
five device but so actually the compiled
it is like a few months before the new
Pluto file specification was released
and the cool part is that the patches
are basically overwriting all the ble 5
functions so beautifies reception
transmissions like all patched it's
awful
so I think it's fine I mean they can
still they can still prioritize you mean
you know like functionality security and
they have like 128 options or I mean on
the Samsung Galaxy s8 they have 256
options if you buy the new Samsung
Galaxy S 10 yet you still have like
almost almost 50 patches to go yeah why
not why not I mean that's that's great
so if there is something wrong with your
Bluetooth DD operating system vendor
definitely has a good option you can go
for its flight mode I only planned to to
leave it at this light and recently my I
was giving an IOT lecture and I said
like IOT is best without IOT or at least
without internet and students were
answering this in the exam and my
colleagues were like did you really tell
it in your in your lecture and I was
like oh might be that I did that so yeah
so I'm not leaving it at this light I
would say so what if the agilent
approach to like not use bluetooth by by
the most recent and most expensive
smartphone so yes support this this
industry
whenever a new smartphone with newer
chips is released trash the old one so
never sell your device of course on eBay
I mean your
I know it and there's data on the chips
to put it in a blender it will blend
still still disable the virus chips if
not needed and best option very tinfoil
hat like my unicorn it's the most secure
unicorn here in the room I would say so
yeah that's let's talk a bit about
security I'm I'm using this great iPhone
se so it has all the pet Ram Dass used
I was rude on this doing [ __ ] camera I
was like it okay I I need a new
smartphone but on the other on the other
end I have tiny hands I have tiny hands
I need an S II yeah and then okay I mean
I I just disabled bluetooth I disable
Wi-Fi just because that's also Broadcom
and then I'm not sure if this if it's a
Qualcomm or an internship I think it's
an internship and then there is a guy
it's part of himself guy he gave a talk
at repo on how he hacked into selling
our stuff so maybe not the best but
what's your smartphone I have a pixel
yes it's secure I'm not sure about but I
definitely know that there's no Broadcom
chip in it but I can sleep better now
but Qualcomm is probably not better yeah
I mean on Def Con they had this Devadas
Chinese people they had this funny heck
on Wi-Fi so Qualcomm has six year boot
and they bypass secure boot because they
first checked the file and then they
were using the file which could be
modified later and then you could boot
with insecure contents and then they
were extracting stuff from the film
there and just the usual thing buffer
overflow pwned that's all you know what
yeah you never know so yeah I was
testing I had a student who made an iOS
proxy and I was like yeah okay it's cool
to have it I might need it at some point
in future he's actually sitting there so
I was like yeah okay cool but let's see
when I need it and first of all I was
like okay but it's high to be rude on on
an iPhone and so on so I don't have that
many jailbroken iphones what do I do
let's just lets us wait that's the best
option let's just wait for Jerry breaks
yeah so iPhones which one should you buy
I don't
there's there's many cutters - Space
Gray yeah which rich color
I don't know like red black one of those
might be more secure then you then you
go to compare you compare iPhones you go
to the website compare iPhone models
it's all about the colors so first
option is choose your color i I don't
know you spread a bit down but it says
two to five so nothing too specific so
what you do is obviously you take your
Nexus 5
open the BTS new block in your hex
editor pair with smartphones and check
the LMP minor version that works great
so I really can recommend stores that
are now official Apple stores so no
customer support is a good thing you
could go here scan smartphones for one
or two hours maybe have someone who
asked you what you're doing and then you
might answer yeah you know I I'm
undecided which one to buy I need to
know the beautiful version anyway just
let me do that
okay so yeah it's fun yeah so I
collected some versions and fun part is
the iPhone XR is having the old ship so
okay yes let's save some money I mean if
you if you buy if you sell a couple of
hundreds of million off iPhone and it's
it's it's okay to go with an old ship I
wasn't rude on one of the most recent
iPhone so I don't know the bit eight of
those would be great to have an
estimation on the security of those
chips geeks are I would probably not
consider it secure but okay I mean it's
three years old yeah at least one good
thing about the effort that's obviously
a positive thing um I have seen that
they prevent an op attack so that's
really cool it works so even on the old
iPhone 6 you would see that someone is
running the new attack against you and
we release the test tool so the original
offer of knob had a very complicated
test tool and ours works at least on
four devices so you can have your
raspberry pi and tests against not if
want so yeah let's do some demo I have
this iPhone 6 with me so first thing you
need to do this being rude on your
iPhone and yeah and then you just do
this
I don't know it's tightest Fanny proxy I
hope it works instantly let's see yes
yes it works instantly so this one is
pretty old and I didn't be too much of
support into it so for some stuff it
would need to put some assembly snippets
into internal ooh which I didn't do yet
but what I always do when I start with
such a few a two hex dump on the serial
position and if the smartphone it's a
bit newer than let's say 2011 2012 so
that's when it starts to have this four
bytes here which is called internally in
the symbols it's called the boot check
so let's start this one
pretty cool because it tells you the
build date so this is how I get the
pipettes so yeah July 15 and 2013 and
even nicer so this one is saying I'm
using the film very decent this because
the chip identify it stays on that so
that's the LMP minor version and it's
also in here you would also get this
version string yeah next thing which I
just know because I know the date so
that's I'm styling to look like in those
I don't know metric films or something
very like have those or all the second
films like tons of hex code and you try
to estimate what's in it so 2013 it's
like the old memory layout where the
petram is like in the very beginning of
the trip which is actually disposition D
0 0 0 0 you can basically check out some
of the firmware files of internal blue
to see where the pet ramus and the
specific thing about pet from is that
it's just as branches into other
locations which I'm not written into the
position D 0 0 0 but into another
position earlier in
so this branch here is not to this
address but it's actually within the
petram DS something and so on so you can
start estimating so this is patches so
you go a bit further like yeah 100 is
still patches
I don't know 200 this is no patches so
this is actually patch code so I go back
to I don't know 180 something and then
this is the end of the patches I think
but for this I would need to look into
the exact patch
Petrus that this break point might also
be a patch so let's go for this number
DS 0 1 FC and I would go into Python do
something like this so serious DS here
what is the address 1 FC minus the base
address and divide this by 4 because 4
bytes by pet RAM slot and then it's the
127 patches so pretty for almost all
patron stars used yeah for some reason
they seem not to use the last one I
don't know if that's like a technical
limitation or whatever so I think on the
raspberry pi 4 you would still have like
one slot left or something and you can
really use it I don't know it's a bit
strange but so it's plus minus 1 or so I
don't know why but yeah basically that's
it yeah so you can do this on iOS
devices or on other devices which is
quite cool and just look a bit into the
chip and the patch level the patches
itself it's harder to analyze them so
you need like a lot of source code to
compare and so on but yeah yeah Android
testing also cool things so we started
with Android
I didn't you say like Android is maybe
not the best idea right yeah when I
started building internal glue I was
building it for Android
because basically my supervisor back
then which was materials he came up with
this idea to look into bluetooth because
he had looked into the Wi-Fi chips which
is basically the same chip because they
are Bluetooth and Wi-Fi combo chips and
he built next model so that the Wi-Fi
part of those chips and then he said
yeah take a look at bluetooth and so I
took a look at Bluetooth in the Android
smartphones but it would have been way
easier to just take a Raspberry Pi and
yeah just do it from a normal Linux
distribution then go through the Android
system and do that but I managed to do
it and now we basically have this
running on all platforms like on Linux
on windows nobody IT security student
who has the most knowledge yeah yes so
yeah so Android testing is also a bit
yeah hi it actually so you go into a
store you you still you again don't know
like what is in a device it's also bit
specific for the my kid so what you buy
here in Europe might be a different
thing and so on then somewhere else so
you need to check what is in the device
so I again go into the store and do the
thing
so the Samsung S Sirius is one of those
who has brought home chips over here and
yeah it's pretty cool they even have
tinfoil colored as an option so I would
I would recommend that of course and
it's actually so you go to the
specifications and the first thing like
for the iPhones once again first
decision is the colour it's really the
first thing in the specs you can check
it's the colour yeah so the first in
Telugu version so how did it brick
yeah this is also recap from last time
so when I started looking into this I
had the Nexus 5 and I knew there was a
Broadcom chip in there and basically
what I also found out pretty early in
this process is that the Android
Bluetooth stack which basically is this
Bluetooth default RSO file on your
Android smartphone it's a shared object
which contains all the Bluetooth stuff
of Android this has several debug
functions which are usually not compiled
into the Bluetooth stack when like when
the Android version is shipped but it's
only for developing so one of the first
projects I did was basically recompiling
this beautiful stock for the Nexus 5 and
enabling all those debug functionalities
and this took quite a while because
basically for this old Android version
you couldn't just build do too few had
to build the whole Android ROM which
took 100 gigabytes of storage and I had
to get me an Amazon instance because my
laptop wasn't as good and yeah basically
when you have those debug
functionalities the the Bluetooth stack
would open up to TCP ports which let you
interact with the HDI protocol layer and
the HDI is basically the host controller
interface so it's the protocol that is
spoken between the host which is the
Android system in this case and the
controller so that brought computer chip
and yeah basically for those two ports
you can sniff and also inject into this
protocol layer and are therefore
directly enabled to talk to the chip
yourself basically in parallel with the
Android Bluetooth stack and what I then
did is just forward those two ports to
my whole system and was able to
basically access them fully into a blue
framework which was written in Python
and the problem with this is for me it
was working fine and I did that for the
Nexus 5 and then it was all good I just
had to replace the Bluetooth 30 fault of
the so file and then everything was fine
however if you wanted to do that on
another Android version like if you
update the Android version of this Nexus
5 or if you go to another device and
they're on another Android version you
would have to do this process all over
again with recompiling enabling debug
and so it was quite cumbersome we did it
for several different devices which you
can now download the precompiled
Bluetooth stack on github but there
still a lot of devices basically missing
where you would have to do that yourself
and this is the problem that he's gotten
faced
yeah I mean a good thing with this copy
that you could also edit the diagnostic
messages where you can see LMP and SCP
which is the layer 2 of bluetooth so to
say but they made this ABI the binary
interface fixed so that you could no
longer add diagnostic messages since
Android 8 without breaking it so I
couldn't compile it the way I liked it
either way since Android 8 so I was like
ok
Bluetooth default I saw does not run out
of the box on a rooted android also on a
more recent Android it would not run the
way I like it with diagnostic messages
so I take whatever whatever crappy
support I can get because what I did
recently is like I have a pile of
smartphones and I update them and after
the update I wrote them once again and I
want to check did they get a specific
security update yes or no and you
wouldn't recompile the the Bluetooth
defer that's our each time and you also
wouldn't do that probably for some
Samsung stock rom and so on so what do
you do well Hecker mode on you install
busybox
you netcat the Bluetooth new block
somewhere and you just directly echo
into the serial interface this works on
Android not not on other devices because
this serial interface of the Bluetooth
chip is not blocking so you can just
echo something despite a Bluetooth is
still running and it really silent it 8
and 9 I didn't test 10 yet I don't have
any Android 10 supported device that has
a Broadcom trip so far so it's a bit
slow in case of like it takes a few
moments until the Bluetooth HDI lock is
written and then netcat it over that
point so if you want to dump the full
room I would recommend you some shell
scripting that echoes into TTY and so on
and then you pass this with Python
afterwards but for for everything else
just like checking how many pet RAM
slots I use what is in a specific Ram
position during runtime and so on it's
perfect
so I have the Bluetooth versions of
several tips here the first one is
pretty
the Samsung Galaxy S 10 II so um I did
not even buy it because it was one of
the most recent ones but over the year
it says this for 208 and this is the
version that I also had for one of the
emulation boards and I was like oh damn
if I have this phone I might have a room
for that I have symbols and that would
be awesome and then you connect locally
average the I and then you get to
version 1 1 1 1 and all the symbols are
at different positions so then but still
it's the newest one that I could get so
far and I definitely have two things
fixed in there that are worth fixing so
I would say like if you really want to
have a Broadcom trip and if they are
just just take the newsman so this one I
would kind of recommend in terms of
being ok not in terms of being good but
okayish and then there is a lot of other
versions which are obviously older and
ds8 with all this the first buta 5 phone
that has like all the blue 5 petals so
hilarious yeah
and then another thing once you're on
the film that you want to start
debugging debugging it's really
important to understand what is going on
and while you are debugging one thing
that happens on all the chips if they
crash they produce a stack dump and just
sorry the stack dump is so they don't
always occur just to stand on certain
crashes and they have a different output
for each and every chip version so the
Nexus 5 you reversed how it works then
the Nexus 6p has another variant of this
then I'm on the evaluation board where I
have cymbals so I know at least what is
going on and why they are so different
and on the relation board I would get
the top part of this listing
but then if I'm on a samsung galaxy s
and E which is almost the same
generation I would get another format of
a stack dump which is slightly different
but almost the same almost the same and
this is the reason why currently
internal blue is parsing some of these
tech Tom's dublicate and might provide
you a duplicate output or something it's
still better to have a duplicate output
anon
and that'sthat's the reason why because
I I don't know what I'm running on I'm
just trying to interpret those events
and hope for the best
yeah but a stack down that's that's the
thing like when it crashes and it's
cooler to do it a bit more defined and
that's something that you were I think
building after your talk back then or
like around this time so definitely
after you Jesus yeah so this was edit
after I already had it in the fuse I
think it was added after my talk last
mmcd so it's a trace point feature which
is basically there to replace debugging
because you can't get back the chip when
it's in the smartphone so what we
thought would be really nice is to note
the exact state of the firmware of the
processor on a certain line of code for
example we found a function that is
pretty interesting but we don't know how
it was called with which like with
parameters and what's the current state
of the stack and usually when you
reverse engineer something like that you
would set a break point and just took it
registers but you can't do it like this
so basically what we do now is just
insert a patch at a specific line of
code where we are interested in which
will just branch away from the current
function into the rum then record all
the registers basically so dump all the
registers and processes state and run
the complete stack and send it over to
the host then remove the trace point
like the patch and then jump back to the
original function so that they can the
function can continue like there
wouldn't have been any trace point but
at least you got a snapshot of how the
state looked like one when the function
hit this point and that helped a lot
during reverse engineering and also when
we found like weird behavior or only if
you want to know if this function is
actually hit or not it already helps
yeah and then I was reading the
breakpoint so as there is no debugger
connected that one would just produce a
straight crash but it's sufficient for
most analysis and this one I don't need
to pour it it just works on any of the
devices but the trace point it's it's
really smooth because you can also read
move to random from the from the trace
points just this this part and then it
would usually never crash you would just
continue continue continue and see what
is happening yeah yeah so the thing is
to add those trace point features you
basically need to already know some
things about the firmware for example
the trace point must be able to like the
code which is inserted with the trace
point must be able to communicate back
to the host so it must know where the
HDI functions are in the firmware and
how to call them and if you don't know
that about any firmware like if you are
on the new firmware version then you can
basically not use this feature so if you
just insert a usual break point that the
chip would basically just crash because
there's no break point handler but it's
enough because it produces a stack dump
and you also know the process of state
you just cannot continue afterwards yep
so that's it so long and thanks for all
the chips thank you
any questions in doing the Q&A via we
are going to show you a video that is
not streamed I think did you or did you
stop the video but you can continue with
the tone and everything and filming us
just not I have I have an awesome video
it's it's about how to disable Bluetooth
properly let me just why why we are
doing tonight so if you have any
questions feel free to ask what this
video is playing because it takes a
while
I think Bluetooth is still working on
this one yes yes yes takes a moment take
someone no questions really whoever has
a phone that probably has a Broadcom
trip
yes one - it must be more it must be any
anyone who has an iPhone that's a
straight yes anyone with a Samsung would
also be a straight yes probably so at
least the Samsung S series not the a
series that might be mixed yeah who I
think so I think like me who a also has
another definitely off I think even
their own chips isn't it high silicon
something
yeah the planner is amazing amazing so I
think Pluto Vista say but now that's
let's do the same 50 Samsung Galaxy s8
really not no questions I have one yes
awesome this one is more robust yeah but
also the plan was already used I I think
it's hard to compare it's really hard to
compare it's a bit unfair competition
yeah so the question is if you looked a
bit into the I was 13 so the problem if
I was 13 is it like you don't have a
trade break what you can do is you can
enable the debugging so you can install
this Bluetooth profile and with this in
iOS 13 you can even do some life logging
actually this is pretty cool so you
would life see all the messages being
exchanged on the iPhone so you can get
an idea of what the chip does but you
cannot interact in that sense yeah
I cannot tell you about this I can only
give you kind of recommendation switch
phones not to buy yeah
[Music]
yep that's correct so if there for some
reason ship the patch that itself
contained a vulnerability or like a back
then of course this would not need
another Petron slot because they could
just change that also if they already
patched something in a function they can
just like add another patch with the
same petram slot in there and branch
back later so yeah there's probably a
lot of things they can do to trick this
system to to even squeeze more out of it
but I guess I really would like to see
those engineers because they're probably
dying to squeeze in all the patches in
those slots we turn five cypress instead
of protocol yeah yeah well when I was
reversing the Nexus 5 I stopped trying
to reverse what those patches are
because it was pretty cumbersome to
reverse what they mean without knowing
the whole context and I didn't have that
much time so basically with a lot of
time you could probably see what they
actually patched and what things they
added but yeah it would be quite
time-consuming and I did not do it and I
think you only know only about a few
sort of thing is what I did is I knew
about certain things that I wanted to
see in the patches and checked if they
are there and then there's other stuff
that I started about just like randomly
so this the fact that the several Galaxy
s8 is like having pitched all the ble 5
is because I had a special thing that I
wanted to do with ble 5 so a feature
that will probably be published in a few
months I don't know so just the cool
feature for for debugging and sniffing
and I was looking for those those
function and just didn't find them and
then they were suddenly in petram yeah
three questions then I think he started
and I don't know and no some months ago
I
on a Raspberry Pi and I use the next
moment project which is developed here
in dumb start and when I remember me you
can increase the rum the internal rum in
the pork on chip in the Wi-Fi yeah in
the Wi-Fi and can you then increase the
the slots tool with this possibility I
don't think so I'm not sure so I didn't
I didn't see that yet I know that in the
configuration of the evaluation board
it's a flag that you set but I think
it's fixed I mean otherwise Vai Vai
either still at 128 pages on on an
iPhone 6 and a see if they could do it
differently also so the patching works
very different differently between Wi-Fi
and Bluetooth in terms of how the page
is generated and applied it's both arms
so there's even a next one - bTW branch
work-in-progress whatever I should I
should finish that one I just didn't
find time yet so they were in the future
there will be Bluetooth and Wi-Fi in a
next one project
I was curious why the change by enabling
the debugging in Android 8 was breaking
the Bluetooth driver what was happening
there okay so Bluetooth has four message
types HCI command which is number one
two and three are ACL and SCO and four
is the event that comes back and the ABI
only knows those four message types and
the diagnostic message is seven for
whatever reason and then you would need
to add a new message type with the new
prefix or embed the other messages into
something but and it would not no longer
be so it just breaks this this
assumption that you have for message
types which is hard-coded in the ABI
okay thanks yeah I can also just repeat
the question the best security
improvement of two to five in we shot
the video right apart from that there is
a lot of legacy stuff but you need to
have it in there to support all devices
yeah it's its heart so this secure
simple pairing was even proven to be
secure and just recently we had like two
attacks on this because of this non
checking of some parameters and so on so
it's highs it's hard to tell like what
to do properly I mean maybe they should
hire a cryptographer in their team to
not have all this insecure encryption I
don't know yeah
yeah to proper security is one thing but
you need to support legacy devices yeah
yeah you could put you have already kind
of special bits because during the
pairing that held a Bluetooth version
and then you would know the version that
you're talking to the device but this
part is not authenticated once again I
don't know
besides also another problem is that
most vendors if they develop a Bluetooth
product they wanted to be compatible
with almost all devices and so they
actually allow that you are pairing with
older Bluetooth versions and if they
would deny that they would probably cut
off half their their customers so this
is another problem that we still have a
lot of old cheap IOT devices which only
support bluetooth for at over 4.1 which
used the less secure Bluetooth le
pairing for example so yeah the solution
would be to switch over to newer devices
which only support new bluetooth and
also to make them so that it they are
not compatible anymore with the older or
at least warn the user hey this is
insecure
yeah but how long did you WEP stick
around how like your question was okay
we have the same problem with Wi-Fi and
there's at some point found a way to
make it secure but yeah if you look back
how long did WEP stick around and was
still a problem and you couldn't like if
you would connect to a network it
wouldn't tell you if it was like vpa or
WEP so the same thing we would need now
for Bluetooth that it wants you hey this
is an old device you're connecting
through are you sure you want to connect
it it's unsecure it yeah must be user
awareness and even very sort of belief
4.1 and 4.2 the scene secured has
exactly the same user experience in
terms of comparing six numbers which is
the secure pile in a new one so it it
would feel the same for the user he
wouldn't feel any difference between an
insecure and a secure pairing mode okay
so there was yeah that one one question
yes right so I wonder it makes sense to
flash the firmware in to roam at the
factory if you really don't need to
change later but it seems that the
Bluetooth firmware changes rather often
so why don't they use similar two
mechanisms to Wi-Fi where the whole
firmware is loaded I'm not sure if that
is going to come so I think they just
didn't have to do so many patches in the
past so there hasn't been a lot of
security research in the past or not
sufficient security research in the past
so they didn't need to do so many
patches and now this is happening and
this is becoming true and they need to
patch all of this and they kind of do it
so maybe they will switch to the
mechanism that I have for Wi-Fi okay
thanks so a hacking Lee and I'm you was
probably cheaper than loading the entire
firmware we'll see yeah okay so we will
be here the remaining day so if you have
any questions we can do some offline
follow-up
also if you check out on the get up the
internal blue project there's also some
examples and also many links to other
conferences we already gave talks where
there are recordings and also papers so
if you're interested in the details then
on the github page you would probably
find what you need
otherwise contact us yeah and so I think
that I always push into github is new
device support so I'm not pushing all
the features for like I mean I do
research and then it has some periods
until I published it but all the new
device support like iOS and coming soon
Mac OS will be there
you
you